California se mantiene en alerta máxima
millones de personas han sido afectadas
por las lluvias torrenciales vientos
feroces y fuertes inundaciones que
afectan al Estado desde Navidad por un
fenómeno conocido como río atmosférico
es decir una franja de humedad que
transporta grandes cantidades de agua de
los trópicos
estamos viendo que este tipo de cosas
ocurren con más frecuencia ahora con el
crecimiento de los incendios y el
aumento de las temperaturas del océano
tenemos mucha más humedad en el aire
después de los incendios que fueron
severos aunque los pronósticos indican
que las condiciones mejorarán al
finalizar la semana alrededor de 8
millones de personas permanecen bajo
alerta de inundación en todo el estado
según el servicio geológico de
California se han sufrido más de 400
deslizamientos de Tierra desde el 30 de
diciembre y los vientos violentos han
derribado miles de árboles además de
causar constantes cortes de energía
provocar daños a residencias y dejar
ciudades enteras bajo el agua
recientemente el Gobierno Federal hizo
una declaración de emergencia y prometió
ayudas a los californianos
el presidente Joe biden declaró que
existe un gran desastre en el estado de
California y ordenó ayuda Federal para
complementar los esfuerzos de
recuperación estatales y locales este
fenómeno no había sido visto en
California en décadas un estado que
normalmente es afectado por fuertes
sequías e incendios forestales
característicos de su clima seco